PROFESSOR: Let's do a case
that this mostly solvable
and illustrates
all these things.
It's a very entertaining case.
It's called Landau-Zener
transitions.
For these two people,
Lev Landau, who you've
probably heard from
Landau and Lifshitz.
He's the first person
that tried to do this.
And Zener did it more carefully.
In fact, apparently
found that Landau
made a factor of two error.
And the paper of Zener,
it's actually quite nice,
and it's a very nice
example that illustrates
the physics of this transition.
So we'll devote the
rest of the lecture
to that Landau-Zener thing.
OK.
So it will give us a
little bit into the spirit
of the adiabatic approximation
in the language that Berry
used.
So Landau-Zener transitions.
OK, Zener and Landau were
interested in molecules,
and some way of
thinking of molecules
is to think of nuclei as fixed,
separated by some distance R,
and then you assume
they are fixed,
and they're separated
by some distance R.
And then you calculate what is
the electronic configuration.
So Zener imagined that you
would have psi 1, one electronic
configuration.
It's a wave function
that depends
on some x's for the electrons,
but it represents the situation
where the two protons,
say, for a simple molecule,
maybe they're more distances,
but in particular, they
are separated by a
distance, R. So that's
an electronic configuration.
Electronic configuration,
protons a distance R away.
And suppose there's another
configuration psi 2 of R.
It's another configuration,
so two configurations.
Two different states.
Maybe in the first
state, the electrons
are in some ground state.
In the second state, they're
in some kind of excited state,
two different configurations.
Now, we could plot.
So we'll have [INAUDIBLE]
here, distance R,
and here's the
cloud of electrons.
We could plot a
graph as a function
of the separation, what are
the values of the energies.
And here is one
possibility for the states.
And here's another one.
And that's the plot of the style
that Zener drew in his paper.
And this represents E1
of R and this E2 of R.
That is the energy of the
first state, the energy
of the second state
as a function of R.
So we are having here--
oops-- two energy eigenstates.
So we have H of R. The
Hamiltonian depends on the R.
And basically you're putting
the two protons, the distance R,
and calculating the
electrons, how they move.
Psi i of x R equals
E i of R psi i of xR.
This is for i equal 1 and 2.
The case that the people
were interested in
was the case where this molecule
here, for example, in the state
2, for this value of R,
there is a critical R 0,
where things, the
levels get very close.
For some value of R, this
molecule, for example,
could be a polar molecule.
A polar molecule is a
permanent dipole moment.
It has plus charges
and minus charges,
not evenly distributed.
So you get a dipole.
And maybe here, the
molecule is non-polar.
And here, it's non-polar.
Here polar.
So if you would follow one
of the energy eigenstates,
there's a critical
value of R, where
the electronic
configuration is such
that it goes from
non-polar to polar
and in the other
energy eigenstate,
it goes from polar to non-polar.
So the question is
well, OK, what--
first of all, what
does all this have
to do with instantaneous
energy eigenstates and time
dependence?
Why are we thinking about this?
The issue is that sometimes,
you can think of this molecules
as forming or being subjected to
extra interactions in which you
will have a process or a
reaction in which the radius
changes in time.
So it's possible under
some configuration
that R becomes R of t.
And then, this Hamiltonian
is a Hamiltonian
that depends on R of t.
This wave functions psi i are
R of t E i's become R of t,
psi i's become x of R of t.
This is an important point.
It's simple, but important.
The most important points
in physics are simple.
But you have to
stop and recognize
that something slightly
new is happening here.
If you have solved this
equation for all values of R,
if you know those
energy eigenstates
for all separations
of the molecule,
you now have found
instantaneous energy eigenstates
if it so happens that
R is a function of t,
because if this is true for any
value of this [INAUDIBLE] R,
well, then this is
true for all times.
Because for any specific
time, this is the R,
the same R is here,
and the same R is here.
And that equation
holds for all R.
So if this can be solved for
all R, this holds for all times.
And you have your instantaneous
energy eigenstates.
You have found those
instantaneous energy
eigenstates.
And therefore, the
instantaneous energy eigenstate
are these ones.
And the instantaneous
energies are this ones.
So many times in quantum
mechanics, you do that.
You solve for the energy
eigenstates for a whole range
of some parameters.
And then it so happens
that those parameters
may change in time.
But then you have found
the instantaneous energy
eigenstates for all times.
So in that picture, we have
the following situation,
in which the energies
now could be thought
if R is some
function alpha of t,
then the same picture would
basically hold true for time
here and the energies
as a function of time,
because as time changes, R
changes, and as R changes,
you already know how
the figure looks.
So this is a figure
of the energy
levels as a function of time.
And now the physical question is
do we get a transition or not?
So the adiabatic
theorem would say, OK,
you should state in your
instantaneous energy
eigenstate, but we're going to
get precisely to this situation
where these things could
be so small, so little,
that there is a possibility
of a non adiabatic transition,
in which you jump to the other
one, because the gap is small.
So this goes to the real physics
of the adiabatic theorem,
can we get an estimate or
a calculation that tells us
how much probability you
have of jumping the gap
and going to the other branch?
That's what we're
going to try to do.
So for that, we'll do
a particular example.
So let's do that.
It's an easy one to begin with.
I'll erase this.
So baby example, toy example.
So take a Hamiltonian,
H of t, which
is going to be of this
form, time dependent one,
but relatively simple.
Elements just
along the diagonal.
OK, that's your Hamiltonian,
two by two matrix,
elements on the
diagonal, but just
simple things, the same thing.
So let's calculate the
instantaneous energy
eigenstates.
OK, sounds like a task.
It's actually pretty simple.
The instantaneous energy
eigenstates are 1, 0 and 0, 1.
They don't depend on
time, because essentially
this Hamiltonian is just alpha
t over 2, 1 minus 1, 0, 0 is--
it's a constant matrix
times an overall factor.
The eigenstates of this
matrix are 1, 0 and 0, 1.
And they are the eigenstates
of this matrix for any time,
because the time goes in front.
The matrix doesn't
quite change shape.
So these are the instantaneous
energy eigenstates.
They are good forever.
To plot this, I will assume from
now on that alpha is positive.
The energy of the
first state is--
well, what do you get when
you add with the Hamiltonian
on this state?
The matrix [INAUDIBLE] and
this is just alpha t over 2.
And the energy of
the second state
is going to be minus
alpha t over 2.
We can plot those
energies, and here
is the energy of the first state
is alpha t over 2 with alpha
positive.
This is like this,
thick output of here.
This is the state 1, 0
is here, 1, 0 is here,
alpha t over [? 6. ?] Here
is the energy E1 of t.
The energy time dependent.
Here is time.
And here are energies.
This is E1.
And then we have the E2 is the
other one that goes like this.
It's state 0, 1.
That's the state 2, 0, 1.
And the energy is E2 of t,
which is minus alpha t over 2.
So it's negative for
large positive time
and positive for the other one.
So these are your instantaneous
energy eigenstates.
OK, and this is not quite
what we wanted here.
We wanted things to
avoid themselves.
But this is going to
illustrate an important effect.
I claim, actually, that the true
solutions of the Schrodinger
equation are in
this case dressed up
versions of the instantaneous
energy eigenstates.
So what I claim is
the kind of-- you
do the adiabatic state
corresponding to this,
the adiabatic state
corresponding to that,
and those are exact solutions.
So there is no coupling
between the states, 1 and 2.
So this is plausible.
So let's write those solutions.
I claim here is
psi 1 of t I claim
is the exponential
of minus i over h bar
integral up to t of E1
of t prime dt prime times
the state 1.
I claim this solves the
Schrodinger equation.
i h bar dt of this psi
should be equal to H psi.
Is it clear?
Yes, I think it's clear.
It solves it,
because if you take
the time derivative of this
thing, it multiplies by E1.
The i h bar cancels that
factor of minus i over h bar.
The time derivatives
brings out an E1 of t.
But this state, despite the
phase when h [INAUDIBLE],,
it goes through the
phase, hits the state 1,
and produces the E1 energy.
So this is solved
by that equation,
and you can do the integral.
It looks OK.
It's exponential of minus i
alpha t squared over 4 h bar 1,
and the state psi 2 of t is the
same exponential with E2 with 2
here, and it's the
exponential of plus i alpha
t squared over 4 h bar 2.
OK.
Let's appreciate
the lesson again.
We got a very simple system,
two levels, crossing--
they cross.
The energy levels cross.
That generally doesn't happen.
You have to have a very special
Hamiltonian for the energy
levels to cross.
We found the instantaneous
energy eigenstate,
and we found two exact solutions
of this Schrodinger equation,
two perfect complete exact
solutions of the Schrodinger
equation that represent
the system doing just zoom,
like that, or doing like that.
Totally oblivious that there's
a state they're crossing,
the Schrodinger equation doesn't
couple them in this case.